good evening everybody and welcome to AI
my name is Robert doar and I have the
great honor and privilege and luck to be
able to host and engage in a
conversation with our guests George Will
who has been for more than 40 years
educating us and entertaining us and
challenging us with his writing about
the public sphere in the American
experiment and he's done it again with
his latest book the conservative
sensibility which like his previous
readings writings in other ways has sort
of tried to provide a guide for us to
navigate the divisions that exist in
American political life and seems to me
George that you make for a modern age
Lincoln's argument that the key to our
future is a reconnection to the
principles of our founding the
Declaration of Independence the
Constitution and I want you to know that
I think the book I want the audience to
know that the book is it provides a
guide and a and a help and a kind of
North Star for how we can get through
this difficult period which is what
you've been doing all these years and so
that's why I'm so grateful for you being
here and I'm so pleased that I can
engage in this conversation well thank
you I look forward to it so when we were
in the back before I said I was gonna
give that nice introduction something
like that and and then I said but let's
get to the questions fast and he said
fine let's do it so if I wanna ask you a
grounding question what are the most
important characteristics of a
conservative sensibility and can you
give you an example of how they lead to
a specific policy position well by
sensibility I mean something more than
an attitude and less than an agenda it's
a way of seen perceiving experiencing
coming to terms with the flux of life
and events Virginia postural a great
Washington figure so the Bible reduced
to one sentence
is God created man and woman and then
lost control of events the consumer the
conservative sensibilities is good we
don't we like control lost the epigraph
of my chapter called conservatism of
that theism is from our Stephanie's
world his king having driven out Zeus
I like world more than Zeus that's the
conservative Sensibility it's Lucretia's
if you will that's things are out of
control and isn't that grand because the
exhilaration of a free society is
exactly that that we don't know the
future people are always saying in
America campaign spending is out of
control
listen that's out of control is it good
yes it's supposed to be out of control
because the controllers are dangerous so
the answer to how it applies to a
particular policy question is to just
throw up your hands and say isn't that
wonderful
not necessarily because it's not always
wonderful to put it mildly but it is to
say that the alternative is worse than
the problems we have from freedom at the
moment uh so there's a lot to talk
around town that you've changed a little
bit you know you wrote a book called
statecraft as Soulcraft
and that seemed to be a conservative
critique of the libertarian view and now
you've written a book that seems to be
the libertarian critique of the
conservative view fair I'm a lino
libertarian in name only I'm a I'm a
libertarian ish him that I say before
the state interview interferes with an
individual's freedom or the two or more
individuals contracting together
voluntarily it ought to have a good
reason and not to say what it is and it
ought to be often submitted to a
judicial supervision to decide whether
or not this the reasons given are real
or pretextual that said in 1981 I gave
the Godkin lectures at Harvard called
and it became a book two years later
read by dozens
the title of which was less important
than the subtitle the title of which was
statecraft of soulcraft the subtitle was
what government does not what it should
do not what it should try to do what it
can't help but do any regime any
structure of laws any chosen political
system shapes the soul of the people
when Jefferson and Hamilton argued in
our first great argument they were
arguing about what kind of people we
were going to be sturdy rural stable
yeoman rather like Thomas Jefferson as
Jefferson wanted or uppity restless
entrepreneurial people like Hamilton
which Hamilton wanted understandably so
I fully understand because I sometimes
libertarians forget that al is a fair
system is a government construction
courts judges contracts laws about fraud
arbitration all the rest it's
complicated and it requires a and
determined government to produce a
political economy that's what we used to
call economics and political economy is
has all the dignity of politics because
it's about how we should live and that's
what I put a tackle arguments are always
about so just to push it on the
libertarians a little further you have a
lying Conservatives task is to build a
society that nurtures individuals to
self-sufficiency and so that means that
in the world that I come from I've
worked in social services programs for
years that it's okay to have a
government that says to people that in
return for assistance we're gonna have a
some case management we're gonna ask you
to go to work we're gonna we're going to
involve some hassle in the in the
interaction between the state and the
citizen in that context no problem for
you no problem at all in the classic
case of this is the GI Bill the GI Bill
said and to 12 million returning
servicemen and women said if you do
certain things that we consider socially
useful buy a house get married go to
college this is an entitlement for you
but it if these were people who had
already rendered
a civic service by serving in the
military and we're going to get a
benefit if they continued in a different
way to render render a service to
society okay so take that libertarians
do a little bit of government is okay
well in that context no UVI for you I'm
trying to find a few conservatives I
haven't defended and get on with it so
now let's talk about Barry Goldwater and
Daniel Patrick Moynihan yes
so you dedicate the book to Barry
Goldwater and of course you write often
and frequently about the great wisdom of
Daniel Patrick Moynihan and very
different senators very different views
very different votes I feel a little bit
like Elizabeth benefit Bennett and Sense
and Sensibility
or Pride and Prejudice actually Wickham
and Darcy you know how can they both be
good well they had different different
tasks Goldwater's task was to rekindle
an argument that had been raging in the
Republican Party like it intermittently
like a sine wave since Teddy Roosevelt
decided he won the White House back and
went to war against his protege William
Howard Taft that fight was replicated
again between Dewey and Taft in the 40s
between Goldwater and Rockefeller in the
60s and it was Goldwater's task it was
not a thinker as he cheerfully admitted
okay he read his book the conscience of
a conservative I think but he was going
to revive a vocabulary of limited
government and of traditional
republicanism I think one of the
greatest events in American political
history was when Teddy Roosevelt's two
of his very closest friends who loved
the man in a huge and Henry Cabot Lodge
refused to support Roosevelt and
supported William Howard Taft had they
not done so we would have had from then
on to progressive parties they didn't in
Goldwater I've often said he people say
he lost because he lost 44 states I say
he won just took 16 years to count the
votes
he had changed the nature of the
Republican Party and the vocabulary we
could talk about it with but I didn't
ask you about Teddy Roosevelt I asked
you about Daniel Patrick Moynihan yes
I'm still trying to find out how Daniel
Patrick Moynihan
and Barry Goldwater get along Pat came
from a tradition of Clubhouse politics
in New York City he was a new dealer to
his the fiber of every cell in his body
he was a new deal man but he loved
politics he loved the give and take of
it this year messiness of it and most of
all he's the finest social scientist
ever to serve in Congress famously said
everyone all people are entitled to
their own opinions but not their own
facts and he grounded arguments
exuberant arguments happy cheerful
arguments he just understood the
messiness of life a woman though he's
just like you liked him
a loaf matter is my best friend ya know
I done vote so his votes knowing Pat
more names the best joy I've had in 50
years ago it's my 50th year in
Washington and just Pat but Churchill
once said the meeting Franklin Roosevelt
was like opening a bottle of champagne
that's how I felt about the path so it
shows that you can love a man you don't
agree with of course I'm coming to good
telling Jess I mean Pat just loved the
give-and-take and swirl of American
politics so in the book there's another
aspect that surprised me and was that
you've clearly turned away from judicial
restraint or reluctance on the part of
chorus to interfere in the decisions of
legislatures could tell us how that
happened and in the hands of a more
progressive Sensibility
isn't that a little dangerous yes
there's no safety in politics the role
like now prescribed for the courts is
dangerous that they will promiscuously
go down a buffet of rights and invent
all kinds of things I just think that's
marginally less dangerous now than the
courts
passivity through the rational basis
test and other matters to an extravagant
unhinged super unsupervised democracy
here's out camera bob bork who I mean I
fought so hard for his confirmation in
the summer and fall of 1987 that my
friend Meg Greenfield running the Post
editorial page the day he was voting on
they ran an editorial dear George trying
to talk me in off the ledge I just
decided I was wrong I decided that
Oliver Wendell Holmes was wrong when he
said if the American people want to go
to hell I will help them it's my job I
do not think it's the job of the
judiciary to facilitate majority rule I
do not think that Alexander Bickel Bob
Bork's friend and colleague at Yale Law
School was right when he said that
judicial review is inherently
problematic because of what he called
the counter majoritarian difficulty
where a majority rule country I don't
think so first of all just as a as a
matter of fact most of what government
does asthma is not responsive to
majorities it is responsive to small
compact intense confident articulate and
well lawyer defections and so
supervising their rent-seeking is not a
counter Megerian problem at all second I
grew up in central Illinois I'm
marinated in the spirit of Lincoln er I
grew up in Champaign Urbana the
Champaign County Courthouse according to
local lore is where Lincoln then a very
prosperous railroad lawyer was traveling
doing business was where he supposedly
learned of the passage of the
kansas-nebraska Act the greatest career
in the history of world politics began
with his recoil implacable canny subtle
but unrelenting recoil against the idea
that we should settle the problem of the
expansion of slavery into the
territories by popular sovereignty and
voted up voted down since Steven a
Douglas the author of it matter of moral
indifference because he said
majority rule is what America's about
Meghan said no we're not about a process
we're about a condition and the
condition is Liberty
big difference so in your sort of
raising above the Constitution of the
Declaration of Independence Jews in
Lincoln's phrase the frame the the
Constitution is the frame of silver for
the apple of gold frames important the
pictures more important Silver's
valuable the Gold's more valuable the
Declaration is the heart of the matter
but in doing so it seems to me you are
allowing judges if they were to turn to
the declaration for instance to create
new rights rights that constitutes a
danger and the other thing it would do
is something that I I always thought you
argued against which was the progressive
or liberal post 1960s attitude that
whenever there was a problem that needed
to be solved go run to the courthouse no
I don't say go run to the courthouse but
I do think there's plenty for the
government for the courts to do in
supervising what the legislators do and
increasingly what that fourth branch of
government called the administrative
state doesn't keep it busy okay so okay
so let's talk about conservatives
conservatives today you say in the book
Lincoln's public life was devoted to
reconnecting the country with the
principles of the founding this this is
conservative isms core purpose today how
are we doing not well but this book
which is the most important event in
publishing since Gutenberg invented
movable type this is about argument this
is what Americans do was argue because
we we are as Margaret Thatcher why as we
said European nations were created by
history America was created by
philosophy not least by her countrymen
John Locke if you don't like arguing
pick another country because that's what
we do is we're constantly arguing about
what unenumerated rights are
the ninth amendment be applied was
Lochner properly decided and of course
it was but that's another matter
no I mean this is the joy of being an
American the exhilaration of politics
George I that strikes me I thought you
were kind of grumpy these days you're
getting joy and a nil exhilaration out
of out of the divisions on the right
well there used to be a show called
fibber McGee and Molly where Molly would
say to her husband if it makes you happy
to be unhappy be unhappy and
conservatives I get a certain pleasure
out of being embattled and and no one
ever wrote political philosophy because
they were happy they didn't they Hobbes
didn't say I'm so contented I'm gonna
write the Leviathan people write
political philosophy because they're
worried or angry or unsettled and I'm
all of those things but I but I'd like
to think I am like Goldwater to whom the
book is dedicated I am a cheerful
malcontents okay so let's talk about
something that that that I I'm curious
about it with regard to the founding
principles it presupposes a depth of
knowledge a goodness in our citizenry
our american people today up to that
it's an open question yeah we're gonna
answer it one way or another because
there was a degree of social capital in
the country in the country as it then
was 4 million people strung along the
eastern fringe of a continent 80% of
them living within 20 miles of Atlantic
Tidewater there was a richness of the
journalistic culture there was a
richness of the literary culture Ric
Atkinson in his new book wonderful book
on the
American Revolution says there were I
think more booksellers in Philadelphia
than in the 11 largest English cities
combined a genuine civic culture that I
think has been diluted partly because
there's so much more government to keep
track of now that people sort of despair
they've given up on it
partly because what we call the social
media and really anti social media
encourages and rewards snarkiness and
gives a serrated edge to American life
and increasingly has people addicted
literally addicted to the dopamine they
get from being angry I think if you'd
map the brains of the average Cable
viewer it would show that their their
pleasure synapses light up the way they
do in the cocaine addicts I'm quite
serious about that I think people are
addicted to the pleasure of being angry
so you're not as maybe never were
comfortable with Churchill's admonition
trust the people Churchill is said to
have said I'm afraid he didn't but he is
said to have said that any cure for
faith and democracy is a five-minute
conversation with the average voter no
trust the people that try but do what
Madison recommended I think what we
should have done before the brexit
referendum would have been the greatest
gift from America since lend-lease
if we had sent them the writings of
James Madison it would have said the
first thing you do is do not try direct
democracy I'm by the way I was for
voting for brexit but not for voting in
referenda Madison said majorities should
rule and whether they should or not
they're going to rule therefore
care must be taken that majority opinion
is filtered and refined and slowed and
delayed and run through institutions so
that in the end you have a republic the
difference between Republic's and
democracies is the principle of
representation on
the people do not decide issues they
decide who will decide but they those
who are deciding these making these
decisions I think you write quite
eloquently in the book are incapable of
making the hard decisions of limiting
government oh they're capable they don't
want to ya know I mean the one thing
Madison got terribly wrong and he can't
be folded for this he could not have
anticipated the modern world in the
modern state he said in one of the
Federalist Papers he said in a democracy
and popular government you will always
see all power sucked into the impetuous
vortex of the legislature exactly the
reverse has been going on for 80 years
now the Congress has been eagerly
spinning off its powers people say
presidents have been usurping powers if
only they had to use serpent the first
substantive words of the Constitution
after the preamble is all legislative
power shall be vested in a Congress of
the United States they have no right to
do this
if this again a properly engaged court
we're enforcing a non delegation
doctrine it would stop it would be slow
it they are delegating to the executive
branch essentially legislative powers
Chris DeMuth alumnus of this
distinguished institution says Congress
today passes Vella T's not laws they say
we should all have quality education and
then they says over to you guys in the
federal bureaucracy fill in the details
that way all the trade-offs and
difficult choices are made by other
people you have often written about the
awful 20th century seems to me I've read
that yes are you how do you feel about
the 21st well basic conservative belief
as things can always get worse and often
a will my book is a summons to
intelligent pessimism not fatalism but
pessimism is simply by understanding
that the ways things can go wrong are
and so you should be worried about them
weary but not fatalistic the 20th
century built on a 19th century proper
to 19th century propositions one is that
history is a proper noun
capital H that it has its own autonomy
that its unfolding laws of development
are vast impersonal forces against which
human agency is not futile but weak
second they denied and this is what the
progressives lit upon at the end of the
19th century in the beginning in the
twenty they denied the reality of human
nature deny the reality of human nature
you get rid of the nuisance doctor and
there's Woodrow Wilson understood of
natural rights and you say human beings
are only creatures that acquire culture
so they acquire whatever culture they
find themselves situated in therefore
and this is the dangerous therefore that
led to Tollett arianism therefore
politics has an enormous jurisdiction
which is to shape the people by shaping
the culture and it's not just possible
it becomes a political imperative and
that is dangerous you write a habit of
deference to excellence in public life
and public spirited self-denial it's a
polite way of saying in praise of
elitism I've never met an American who
says you know what I'd really like for
presidents that are solid mediocrity we
would really don't want that I mean we
know that we live in journalism and
dentistry in theology under the tyranny
of the bell-shaped curve some people are
god-awful some people are really
terrific and most people in the middle
or mediocre the trick the question is
not whether elites are going to rules
whoever rules is definitionally an elite
the question is and the problem of
democracy is to get consent to were the
elites
I think it's a formulation of a great
API ornament Walter burns to get consent
to wear the elites a little bit of sort
of international question here I know
it's not much in the book but I wonder
how the conservative Sensibility informs
the way you respond when you see a
million Chinese in the streets in Hong
Kong I have a son who lives in Hong Kong
now and it's a it's it's thrilling
because Hong Kong like Taiwan in this
direction and South Korean another are
enormous ly successful outposts of open
societies and there's an attempt to
close Hong Kong to make it a closed
society and it's thrilling and it
illustrates there is a chapter in the
book on on going abroad it's a phrase I
took from John Quincy Adams 1825 great
state paper we do not go abroad in
search of monsters but there is a
tension in American foreign policy we
represent an epistemological assertion
by our founders they said some things
are knowable they are self-evident by
that the founders meant they were
apparent to all minds not clouded by
superstition since we are custodians and
exemplars of these doctrines that we
think have universal applicability not
to everyone not at all times not
everywhere but they are universally
valid in circumstances where they can
flourish there is a tension in our
politics on the one hand we want to
spread the word on the other hand we
have to be aware of the viscosity of
societies particularly not our own we
need to know that the phrase
nation-building is about as absurd as
the phrase orchid building nations are
not Tinkertoys you pull apart and
reassemble and orchids are not built
they're organic flowers and so you have
this tension this almost his invitation
to a messianic foreign policy in our
Universal
Declaration and the prudence all
prudence amounts to is applying general
principles to messy reality and the
prudence required to balance those two
so you have reaction to a million
Chinese in the streets of Hong Kong is
throwing limits
America should speak up it should say
that well I mean it celebrated the two
systems formulation I mean that's a it's
a difficult position Hong Kong is in but
we should be verbally and in other ways
on their side the book is full of condom
Nations of Woodrow Wilson and not FDR
less so after you are could you just
give us a little sense of why you hold
the former president of Princeton and
governor New Jersey more accountable for
our woes I have often said that the most
important decision taken in the 20th
century was not Germany Saudi yeah
Austria after Sarajevo and not Hitler's
decision to invade the Soviet Union and
not done shoppings reforms of China the
most important decision taken in the
20th century was where to locate the
Princeton graduate school
president of the university Woodrow
Wilson wanted it down on the campus his
nemesis Dean Andrew Fleming West wanted
it where it is up on a hill overlooking
the campus Woodrow Wilson having
suffered one defeat too many had one of
his characteristic Tantrums resigned
went into politics and ruined the
twentieth century I exaggerate somewhat
and simplify a bit but Woodrow Wilson
was the first president to criticize the
American Founding which he did not do
peripherally he's sweeping in the
political science of the day science was
in the air when he came in Wright
brothers Marconi Edison Ford and the
belief enunciated most by Herbert
Crowley in the promise of American life
a book published in 1909 and never out
of print since then he said look we're
going to apply science to society and
the first thing we have to do is get rid
of the doctrine of natural rights
because that is what he called
fourth-of-july rhetoric he said
explicitly said don't read the first two
paragraphs of the Declaration it'll only
mislead you get rid of the doctrine of
natural rights because that implies that
governments are instituted among men to
secure those rights first come rights
then comes government and that
inherently limits the state second he
said we must get rid of separation of
powers which was alright once when there
were so few of us but now there were a
great nation held together by copper
wires and steel rails we need a more
nimble government one of his favorite
words able to act with dispatch at the
promptings of a strong executive
remember Wilson to get an advanced
degree in the second half of the 19th
century Americans went to Germany that's
where the degrees were and some of them
came back to teach Woodrow Wilson at
Johns Hopkins and they learned in
Germany that to respect the Bismarck
ian's state and the Hegelian view of
unfolding history that justified the
Bismarck ian's state so Woodrow Wilson
set out to emancipate us from
the founders thoroughly the natural
rights doctrine the doctrine of the
separation of powers and all the rest he
and the rest were forthright about this
they wrote that the founders got it
wrong and that the founders were an
anachronism we could no longer afford to
to worship and they've been amazingly
successful so one last question about
some talking about presidents and
politics where is the political home for
someone with a conservative Sensibility
we're homeless at the moment but it's a
it's it's not a bad thing you know
well no it's I'm just saying that what a
political party's not it's not like
leaving a church political party's a
utilitarian device and when it quits
being useful you change and parties go
through periods where they have to be
mad the Democrats have had their periods
and the Republicans are having one now
but sobriety will come back to them I
think if enough people argue
persuasively enough so since you
mentioned Church a lot of the young
people here at AEI and others want to
make sure I bring this up what about God
and faith well I have as someone said
when he presented Napoleon with a volume
about political philosophy Napoleon said
you do not mention God he said I did not
need that hypothesis or as Bertrand
Russell said when he was famous atheist
of course someone said what happens if
you die and you're brought before God
and he says why wouldn't you
faithfulness tell him you did not
provide enough evidence
IIIi have described myself as an amiable
low voltage atheist I grew up in a
secular household my father's father was
a Lutheran minister therefore he was my
he was an atheist no it was he used to
sit outside Pastor Will's study can
appear the pastor and some of his more
thoughtful congregants wrestling with
the problem of reconciling Free Will and
Grace and it made my father a
philosopher again and I just grew up in
a family where that question didn't come
up I think Bill Buckley got it right
bill said a conservative need not be
religious but he can not despise
religions and the world's great
religions address universal perennial
human doubts worries aspirations not the
deism of our founders that was just I
mean a religion should console explain
and enjoin deism explains something
someone said deism is worships the god
that wins our sundials or the deist god
is like a rich aunt in australia
benevolent but rarely heard from but i
just don't think it's necessary and in
fact i go beyond that i say that welcome
the chapters epigraph called
conservatism about theism the epigraph
some Aristophanes world is king having
driven out zeus again the conservative
sensibility welcomes world okay I got it
that'll take I'm married to a first
presbyterian
the okay let's open it up for questions
from the audience I've done my best with
this assignment right here wait for Mike
yes and we like questions as opposed to
statements here you go
what effect has moral relativism had on
social capital in this country well
obviously the the idea and it's an idea
of enormous consequence that whatever
feels good works for you
that the liberation of an expressive
ethic is the only ethic one needs to
have results in the rapid dissipation of
social capital the habits mores customs
dispositions necessary for thriving in a
free society and taken advantage of its
opportunities as a EEI is charles Murray
says the problem is that today's
bourgeois do not preach what they
practice they preach a kind of
libertarianism that is toxic for people
who do not have the family structure to
transmit the social capital that we have
as a society accumulated and the result
the resulting family disintegration is
unquestionably America's principle
domestic problem when Pat Moynihan wrote
his famous report in 1965 when he was a
38 year old social scientist and Lyndon
Johnson's Labor Department and he said
we have a national crisis because
twenty-three point seven percent of
african-american children are born out
of wedlock today at seventy two percent
forty percent of all American first
births are out of wedlock a majority of
mothers under 30 are not living with the
fathers of their children Pat said at
the time the lesson of history is clear
from the wild Irish slums of the East
Coast in the 19th century to south los
angeles today when you have a large
cohort of adolescent males raised
without fathers in the home you have
chaos
I've raised three boys I know that the
whole point of civilization is to
civilize adolescent males and that's
what happens okay here way in the back
there yes thank you so much for coming
here today so it seems that you're
defining the conservative sensibility as
trying to protect what was essentially a
liberal project which was the founding
small-l liberal so how would you respond
to a trend in conservatism today in
conservative circles and discourse that
is actually critiquing that very project
that small-l liberal project I'm
thinking of books like Patrick de nimes
yes however ilysm failed all of that I
got it I know they're tired of losing
the culture wars and they they blame
small-l liberalism for as I say in the
book that American conservatives are the
legatees of classic liberalism
they are the those who are defending
individualism not denying that all
individuals are socially situated and
that the society matters in its
promptings but saying the individualism
and individual achievement are not
oxymorons
my point is this the point of classic
liberalism and American conservatism in
the phrase American conservatism the
adjective does a lot of work
European conservatism particularly
continental European conservatives
throne and all
blood and soil tribalism if you will
existed to defend existing hierarchies
and to at least slow the subversion of
established institutions the bridge to
America came through Burke whose
understanding of the organic viscosity
of British society sort of typifies by
his famous passage where he talks about
the British cow chewing its cud beneath
the tree while noisy crickets make all
the racket but the British cow is solid
and stable that was an anticipation in a
way and it's certainly of family
resemblance to what Hayek celebrates as
a spontaneous order of society the
extraordinary fecundity of an open
society and karl popper's phrase by the
time you get to the United States
American conservatism exists to
reconcile people to the hazards but also
the exhilarations
of an open-ended society of careers open
to talents of the unpredictability of
things now if people want to find
meaning and identity in politics they
can try but we have seen in the 20th
century the dangers of investing
politics with an essentially religious
role we've seen we live with daily
investing presidents with the kind of
secretarial rule interpreting the
meaning of American and being our moral
tutors and all the rest if people in a
liberal society find that politics does
not satisfy their inner yearnings and
they can't find satisfaction elsewhere
that's not liberalism or classic
liberalism or conservatism fault it's
their fault frankly and they shouldn't
blame the fact that politics does not
serve up this kind of encompassing
experience and spiritual identity don't
blame it on politics because politics
gets really dangerous when people find
meaning in life through collective
action
I want to follow up on that a little bit
because it seems to me you're all so
don't blame public policy for hardships
or hard hard times or difficult
circumstances that there's a lot in the
book where you you kind of are calling
out Americans too who look to the
federal government to solve all their
problems you kind of call it out to pull
up your socks and solve your own
problems stiffen your sinews and summon
up the blood and all that yes yeah I do
you do yes to a certain extent so this
this all this whole concern about the
struggling working class it you you two
mice you find you you weren't concerned
by an effort to respond to that with a
public policy I don't know program I'm
I'm concerned about doing what Donald
Trump did and shouldn't have mentioned
that Matt I didn't know we were doing so
he went to Northeastern Ohio in the
closing days of the 2018 2016 campaign
and said to the people who's got a
mobile jobs for going away said don't
move don't sell your house the jobs are
coming back well they're not when the
Joad family in Grapes of Wrath was
blindsided by two enormous events the
Dust Bowl and the depression they packed
up and moved I'm not saying everyone
should do this but that's an important
part of the response to economic
dynamism the American people have
whether they know it or not have chosen
economic dynamism because they have
chosen to have an entitlement state
making enormous calls on the future
productivity of our society as
entitlements they had better attend to
the productivity it is too late to pull
up the walls and to say protectionism
isn't order because freedom is simply
too wearisome and stressful they've got
to find ways to accommodate themselves
to economic dynamism or we're going to
have an even more curdled polity of
distribute
of politics carving up a static pie
so just regardless of what the
declaration says about all men are
created equal
president Kenny was still right life is
unfair and he would if Kennedy were with
us today he'd say proof of this not that
his family didn't prove it itself but
proof of this is that far too much of
the trajectory of far too many Americans
lives is predictable if you simply know
their families far too much is
determined by family and as society
becomes more cognitively stratified
which is our future the more we realize
that even universal free public
education even if done well which it
rarely is cannot equalize the ability of
people to add value to the modern
economy we have an increasingly
difficult problem Ben says senator sass
notes that the most the largest job
category in America is driver it is the
top job category in 39 states what's
gonna happen when autonomous vehicles
come along yeah we are we are facing
dislocations of a sort we've never seen
before since you did mentioned well let
me create what Ben Sasse says is we've
seen it before actually it's something
like it in the enormous rapid shift from
an agrarian society as people moved to
the cities when we industrialized in the
late 20th century and late 19th century
early 20th century the result then was
gangs alcoholism of a terrible sort so
we've been through these wrenching
things before but we found ways to cope
with them and what I'm all I'm saying is
we should do all we can in a civilizing
humane way to help people adjust to
dynamism but we have no choice okay next
question yes right there
next to you all
that's great in your interview with
Jonah Goldberg on c-span after going
through this apparently justified
evisceration of Woodrow Wilson you
nonetheless added the comment somewhat
under your breath if I interpreted it
correctly that nonetheless
if the modern-day Woodrow Wilson were
running against our current incumbent
you would vote for Woodrow Wilson and
I'm not going to apologize for bringing
this up because in the arena that's
where we live that's where the soulcraft
happens from whoever is in the White
House from your current writing a recent
writing I see you make the note that you
would only vote against mr. Trump if you
could be assured of a Republican Senate
and for that could you tell us because I
think your absence from the Republican
Party is much more important than then
perhaps you give it you give it weight
could you assure us then were you not
assured of a Republican Senate you do in
fact find support of the party with the
current incumbent would be your choice
in terms of all of the ideas that you've
presented here tonight and which side of
the aisle is more likely to be moving
them forward it depends a bit on whether
the other party is determined to prove
that what it did in 2016 was not a fluke
that is it taken again elect Donald
Trump
the there's some good candidates on the
other side not a lot but a few and if
John Delaney somehow wins the Iowa
caucuses all bets are off
but look I I am I really don't want to
talk about him I make it a point to
rarely write about him but I think there
is I have written this recently and I
will repeat it I think the damage he is
doing to I called it aesthetic grounds
but they're not trivial the aesthetic
damage to the country's public life the
fact that you can't unring these bells
you can't say we're going to go back to
saying certain kinds of discourse are
unacceptable again I think they're more
damaging than Nixon's surreptitious
burglaries and cover-ups were because
they're public and they're unapologetic
and the cost to our country is
incalculable because we've never had to
calculate with this kind of thing before
ever we've never had a president
overseas quoting a mass murderer at the
head of North Korea misquoting him of
course at the head of North Korea saying
yes I agree the Joe Biden's and low IQ
idiot just the cost of this which has
been normalized so quickly is I think
incalculable and if the cost is having a
Democrat with him I disagree on every
public policy issue I would weigh that
and be a close call for me more damaging
but not as impeachable perhaps I you
can't impeach a president for keeping
his promises he promised to be a bore he
promised to be to overturn our norms
he's just keeping his promises so
turning to a public figure who may be be
happier with or maybe not
Senator McConnell who sort of made it
his his role in life to stop
bad things being done by the United
States Congress is he is he living up to
the conservative sensibility that you
would desire well let me uh I've known
that he and I were on the Senate staff
and approximately the same time so we've
been around this long time and what
Senator McConnell says the Senate is in
the personnel business its staffs the
federal of the executive branch and that
confirms the article the people on the
article three courts that's a lot to do
and I'm gonna do it and I can't control
the rest he's gonna deal with what he
can control I think well I said this to
him I wrote it and he reminds me of it
frequently that they were wrong not to
give a hearing to and frankly should
have confirmed Merrick garland that was
a peace offering from Barack Obama a 64
year old 65 by the time they were gonna
rap to a judicial nominee of impeccable
experience on the second most important
court in the country I didn't agree with
him on lots of stuff in the
administrative state but it was a peace
offering they should have taken it but
that's just me
if all he does is personnel and nothing
else in them
I would I would alter the Senate rules
regarding the filibuster so that they
could not filibuster a motion to proceed
so that they have to hold the floor
seriously inconvenience everybody and
disrupt things so that a filibuster will
concentrate people's minds on getting
over it okay right here I've gone to the
back now we're coming to the front sorry
hi carl galavan they've mentioned both
Trump and Kennedy and I asked my
question ultimately is if you can speak
about the conservative values of
pursuing peace and also transparency
just yesterday was the 56th anniversary
of John Kennedy's piece of speech in
American University where he called for
all the nations
east and west to pursue strata strategy
for peace and with respect to
transparency Trump avoided his
opportunity to have all the
assassination records of Kennedy
released he's postponed that and he also
promised if elected we would know who
really brought down the World Trade
Center towers and as a 911 responder I
object that those record related
information is still concealed well
there is too much secrecy as my friend
Pat Moynihan wrote a book on it in which
he know with an eye on conservatives he
said you have to understand secrecy is
government regulation most regulations
tell us what we cannot do secrecy tells
us what we cannot know it is absurd that
the CIA's history of the Bay of Pigs has
not been released and it is high time
for all for as much transparency as
possible and the idea that we're
protecting 50 some years after the
Kennedy assassination sources and
methods it's I agree with you we should
err on the side of of openness
you know edited FBI notes of interviews
with no but we're going to hear in about
eight years I think the tapes of Martin
Luther King that have recently been in
the news that's a difficult question
because we don't know how they gathered
them and we want to make sure they've
not been edited but a grown up Society
has to face things like this okay one
last question we'll go right here Larry
right there thank you very much Robert
your impressions are of God in the
public square in our politics how do you
feel about that number two for he who we
will not name what impact has he had on
conservativism and more importantly the
Republican Party well it's a the party
is more homogeneous under him than it
has ever been in its history the 500 day
mark can Reagan's presidency had the
support of if 77 percent of Republicans
500 day mark of mr. Trump's presidency
in the sport of 87% it's now above that
I think it's his party for now go to God
more manageable subject any day now the
Supreme Court is going to rule on
whether the piece cross six miles from
here in Bladensburg Maryland can stand
it's a cross it's on public property it
wasn't originally on public property and
now is the question is does this a bunch
of cranky secularists have said this
violates the Establishment Clause I
think the court is going to say that
indeed there this is not a proselytizing
event this is not an endorsement of a
religion across at the time this was for
World War one veteran's it was the
common symbol of a fallen person in
public and in a heroic endeavor and
they're going to say get over it quit
trying to scrub the public square of
important features of America's ongoing
civic culture and they will be right to
do so half of half of half of my readers
I'm convinced think I'm a Catholic
because I'm pro-life that's not a I'm a
pro-life not because of medieval
theology but elementary high school
biology there's another human being
there that's just a fact now I do I'm
not one of those who says abortion is a
question that precludes splittable
differences there is a middle ground
here and the the the real extremists in
this case are on the other side who are
saying that there is no moral
significance at any stage in human
gestation that it until the moment of
birth the preborn child has the moral
status of a tumor in the mother's
stomach or a hamburger now I happen to
believe that that's wrong that that is
dangerous and differences can be split
here I would like us all to thank George
Will
[Applause]
[Music]